[Musique]
vous souvenez vous la dernière fois où
vous a posé cette question mais toi
qu'est-ce que tu rêves de faire quand tu
seras grand
est ce que vous vous en souvenez moi
j'avais 8 ans la dernière fois on m'a
posé cette question et j'avais alors de
rêve
je voulais être cycliste cycliste
professionnel c'est possible pour imiter
mon cousin qui ont lombardie gagnait
toutes les courses auxquelles il a
participé et je voulais également
traversé ce mythique continent nord
américain les états unis d amérique
certainement inspiré des séries télé des
années 80 et puis je ne sais pas si les
choses se sont déroulées pour vous comme
pour moi mais ces deux rêves d'enfants
je les ai mis dans un coin de ma tête
et puis avec le temps les contraintes
les obligations la vie d'adulte
je les ai oubliés et puis il ya il ya
huit ans en l'espace de quelques mois ma
vie d'homme de père de chefs
d'entreprises a totalement basculé un
divorce entraînant les ventes de parts
sociales dans l'entreprise que j'avais
créé six ans plus tôt entraînant le
chômage et l'isolément le plus total
j'étais donc seul chez moi je ne voyais
plus mes enfants je n'avais plus de
travail et je me souviens encore la nuit
du 24 et 31 décembre généralement
consacrée au partage familial est seul
chez moi
allongés à même le sol regardant le
plafond et à me dire waouh c'est quoi la
suite de l'histoire en fait c'est quoi
le reste de ma vie et à partir de ce
moment là j'ai réussi à me reconstruire
il ya trois choses qui ont été
importantes pour moi ça a été de me dire
si demain je venais à disparaître
quelle valeur j'ai envie de transmettre
à mes enfants la deuxième la deuxième
chose qui est importante pour moi c'est
si demain j'ai un de mes enfants qui qui
qui venait mort mais son papa j'ai un
rêve
j'avais envie de lui dire ben moi aussi
j'ai eu un rêve et j'ai cru je me suis
accroché et j'ai réalisé la troisième
chose justement c'est que ces choses-là
ces moments difficiles on fait re surgir
35 ans après ses deux rêves d'enfants
vieux de plus de 35 ans et j'ai décidé
de les réunir pour n'en faire qu'un
faire du vélo sur les mythiques routes
américaines
et c'est comme ça que je me suis
retrouvé en juin 2015 à los angeles
quelques kilomètres en dessous de los
angeles en californie avec mon vélo et
j'ai donc décidé de traverser la
californie donc la californie pour ceux
qui ne connaissent pas c'est un état un
état très vallonné avec des vergers à
perte de vue et puis j'ai continué j'ai
traversé l'arizona et ses déserts on va
en parler tout à l'heure et puis j'ai
continué j'ai traversé l'utah et les
déserts les terres rouges des indiens
d'amérique
j'ai tourné à droite et puis j'ai
continué j'ai traversé le colorado le
colorado ces 54 sommet de plus de 4000
mètres d'altitude donc c'est un état qui
est juste magnifique
j'ai donc continuer puisque j'avais un
vent porteur donc j'ai traversé le
kansas le kansas et 1 est à plat comme
la main avec des lignes droites de 70 km
puis j'ai continué j'ai traversé le
missouri lyndiane à l'illinois l'ohio la
virginie de l'ouest et je suis arrivé à
un petit port de pêche qui s'appelle
annapolis juste en dessous de washington
et j'avais ainsi donc réaliser mon rêve
parcouru 4960 km à travers le continent
nord américain
mais si vous m'avez bien écoutez vous
aurez remarqué qu'il s'est passé cinq
ans entre le moment où j'ai eu l'idée et
le moment où je vais réaliser mais
pourquoi cinq ans et bien en fait je ne
vous ai pas tout dit et je vous laisse
découvrir
lynn pascoe
moi j
yes he and it's like
sans doute par jeu
tél
de moscou
[Musique]
on
oh
[Rires]
[Musique]
oh
[Rires]
[Musique]
oh
testa
à make a wave
oh
[Musique]
ouais ouais c'était preuve appelé
l'arrêt ce cross america la traversée
des états unis à vélo fait donc quatre
mille neuf cent soixante kilomètres pour
être précis c'est une course une épreuve
cycliste d'ultra distance que la presse
sportive qualifie comme une des épreuves
les plus difficiles après le vendée
globe challenge alors quel est le
principe de cette épreuve
tout d'abord il faut être qualifiés pour
participer à cette épreuve il ya
quarante huit épreuves autour de la
planète qui vous permet d'être qualifié
pour ce type de course
et puis vous avez donc 54 points de
contrôle tout au long du parcours dont
deux sont éliminatoires c'est à dire que
si vous ne passez pas dans les délais
vous êtes éliminés donc on parle de
delhaize justement la course vous fait
traverser le continent nord américain
mais le règlement lui vous impose de le
traverser en un maximum de 12 jours sous
les sphères le calcul 4960 km en 12
jours c'est à dire qu'il faut réaliser
sur son vélo mais un minimum de 400
kilomètres par jour pour arriver dans
les délais donc ces deux points de
contrôle sont éliminatoires et vous
pouvez choisir la manière dont vous êtes
enfin avec comment vous voulez faire
cette épreuve si vous voulez la faire
seule
en équipe de 2 2 4 ou 2 8 la seule
obligation que vous avez c'est d'avoir
une équipe d'assistance autour de vous
qui vous protège qui vous hydrate qui
vous aliments qui vous conseille
car rapidement vous n'êtes vous n'êtes
plus vraiment vous n'êtes plus vraiment
vous même seuls les seuls les fous
peuvent être au départ de cette épreuve
est malgré tout quarante pour cent
seulement des personnes qui sont départ
tous les ans termine laventure donc à
60% des inscrits qui ne sont pas à
l'arrivée
et cette année a lieu dans quelques
jours d'ailleurs la 36e édition
donc c'est donc comme ça que je me suis
retrouvé en juin 2015
au départ de cette épreuve on le voit
sur la photo
donc en fait j'étais euphorique heureux
très contents d'être au départ de cette
épreuve juste incroyable mais en même
temps sur cette photo je suis mort de
trouille
puisqu'en fait je vais avoir des
réponses à toutes les questions j'ai pu
me poser est ce que ma préparation au
cours des cinq dernières années était la
bonne est ce que mon équipe est prête
est-ce que je vais pouvoir réaliser mes
rêves qu'est ce que vont dire mes
enfants donc bref à ce moment là alors
que le speaker en train de faire le
décompte c14 j'ai juste envie de lui
dire stop en fait je vais je vais
réfléchir si je veux vraiment y aller
mais je n'ai pas eu le choix en fait je
suis parti et c'était une aventure
vraiment vraiment formidable mais c'est
vrai que se lancer dans cette aventure
c'est aussi réalisé trois défis un défi
de préparation à défi physique et à défi
mental
le défi de préparation ces deux c'est de
tout mettre en oeuvre pour se laisser
une chance de terminer l aventure c'est
de préparer un plan d'entraînement des
mois al avance strictes auxquelles il
faut se tenir quel que soit le temps
quel que soit la météo
tout en travaillant parallèlement bien
évidemment s'est également constitué une
équipe sans laquelle rien n'est possible
une équipe que je tenais également à
remercier aujourd'hui devant vous
puisque sans elle je ne serais pas là à
vous expliquer ce que j'ai réalisé
et le défi de préparation c'est
également de trouver des partenaires des
partenaires financiers des partenaires
matériels sans lesquels rien ne serait
possible
ça c'était le défi de préparation le
défi physique c'est de traverser le
continent nord-américain en commençant
par l'ouest bien évidemment et c'est
désert ensuite quelques jours après le
départ vous êtes en altitude et il faut
surmonter le froid des sommets enneigés
des rocheuses et puis ensuite il faut
affronter l'humidité de l'est américain
sur cette photo il fait 50 degrés je
suis dans le désert de
à la sortie de la californie il fait 50
degrés 50 degrés pour vous donner une
petite image
c'est comme si on vous pressaient dans
le dos le seul objectif justement c'est
de vous et écrasée au sol
donc on on a trouvé une solution très
simple pour faire face à ça dans déjà je
me suis énormément hydrater puisque ce
jour là j'ai vu 20 litres d'eau donc
c'était un litre par heure par heure où
les voilà et donc on a trouvé une
stratégie qui est peut-être s'arrêter
toutes les 20 minutes où je me
retrouverais de glace et je repartais 20
minutes voilà donc on a passé la journée
la journée comme ça et c'était un vrai
défi sachant que 70 % des coureurs sur
cette première journée souffre
d'associations
l'autre défi l'autre défi physique c'est
la gestion de l'alimentation
une journée comme aujourd'hui avez vous
une idée du nombre de calories
nécessaires au bon fonctionnement de
votre organisme
il est situé entre 1600 et 2000 2002
sans calories sur cette épreuve mon
besoin se situer entre 16000 et 20 mille
calories par jour alors qu'un bon c'est
fait sachant que les spécialistes le
disent plus de 6000 calories en solide
le corps humain ne supporte pas donc je
suis passé sur le de l'alimentation
liquide en grande partie mais pour vous
donner un petit peu plus de contexte
c'est comme si je vous demandais
d'ingurgiter à big mac toutes les 30
minutes pendant 11 jours
voilà ou alors vous vous souvenez du
slogan d'une pub qui disait un marx et
ça repart
c'est comme manger à mars toutes les dix
minutes pendant 11 jours
je vous laisse imaginer au dixième jour
de course et aux 1500 32e mars
l'envié y était pas pas vraiment là bref
vous l'aurez vous l'aurais imaginé c'est
vraiment un vrai défi de préparation qui
s'anticiper les cinq années les cinq
années de préparation vraiment été
importante et nécessaire les blessures
puisque bien évidemment les blessures
arrivent très très vite dans cette
épreuve
donc comme beaucoup de coureurs j'ai
souffert des tendons des articulations
j'ai perdu la sensibilité de six doigts
de la main en fin de mes mains voilà qui
sont revenus bien évidemment six mois
après
mais j'avais six doigts où je ne sentais
j'avais plus du tout de sensibilité le
principe est le suivant c'est qu'en fait
sur votre vélo pendant 11 jours vous
avez que cinq points d'appui vos deux
pieds et vos deux mains et votre selle
et dans le désert vous n'avez qu'une
envie c'est de vous rafraîchir
donc vous vous arrosez énormément ce qui
est une énorme erreur puisque la
transpiration stagner dans votre
cuissard et c'est un véritable cocktail
qui fait que en fait à la selle ça vous
coupe
pour vous donner une petite idée c'est
très désagréable quand vous avez une
ampoule au pied pour marcher on est bien
d'accord il a pour en plus c'est bien
décoller c'est imaginer la sensation à
la selle j'avais 12 coupures comme le
petit doigt et là c'est là que vous avez
une une importance à constituer votre
équipe puisque le kiné qui était avec
moi trouver une solution pour justement
soigner ses blessures très rapidement
alors elles n'ont pas disparu mais en
tout cas j'ai pu les supporter pendant
la traversée et finir cette épreuve mais
cette réussite
cette réussite a été une multitude des
chèques auparavant puisque là cette
épreuve a été réussie on est allé au
bout mais on a testé on a fait des tests
de nombreuses fois dans l'est dans les
mois qui ont suivi
je vous donne à nouveau un exemple dans
mes phases de préparation puisque j'ai
traversé la france en long en large et
en travers pour me préparer chaque nuit
entre à peu près une heure et 4 heures
du matin le symptôme est elle même j'ai
été pris de nausées de vomissements
comme quelqu'un qui descendait d'une
attraction est donc ce qui nous laissait
2h 2h30 à même le sol pour essayer de
récupérer alors on essayé de changer mon
alimentation on essaie de changer ma
vitesse et le résultat est elle-même
donc on est on est on s'est renseigné et
en fait il se trouvait que
je souffre de l'oreille interne enfin
j'ai un problème avec mon oreille
interne et la solution que nous à
trouver c'est que dès que la nuit
tombait toutes les 90 minutes
je m'étais pied à terre je marchais 200
m et ensuite je remontais sur mon vélo
et je repartais sa permettaient de
rééquilibrer mon oreille interne mes
voiles et voiliers le genre de défi
physique que c'était preuve que c'était
preuve vous impose et puis vous avez le
défi mental
le défi mental c'est la gestion du
sommeil puisque c'est une épreuve où il
n'ya pas d'étape c'est à dire que c'est
le premier qui est le premier qui a
traversé le continent américain qui a
gagné chaque coureur gère son
alimentation son sommeil comme il le
veut donc je roulais en moyenne 20
heures par jour et ce qui me laissait à
peu près trois heures
si j'enlève les massages des soins trois
heures pour dormir et se c'était des
micro sieste de 15 minutes qui étaient
étalés et cette photo a été prise 24
heures avant d'arriver à peu près je
m'endormais sur mon vélo et donc j'ai
fait une pause de 15 minutes je mettrais
je mettais je pense à peu près 2 du
monde pour m'endormir
c'est assez rapide tellement j'étais
épuisé mais il ya une vraie vraie
gestion puisque la fatigue vous enlève
beaucoup de filtre et j'ai été victime
de nombreux hallucinations la nuit
notamment
il faut aussi se préparer mentalement à
gérer la peur que vous pouvez avoir
durant cette épreuve parce que vous êtes
sur route ouverte et les camions les
groupes rock américain qui m'avait fait
tant rêver dans les séries américaines
comme j'étais enfant sont vite devenu un
cauchemar durant cette épreuve
donc tout ça c'est une question
d'émotion la gestion des monceaux des
émotions pardon est également très très
importante dans cette épreuve puisque
vous ne pouvez pas rester concentré 20
heures de suite sur votre vélo un moment
donné vous vous déconcentrer et au
moment où vous vous déconcentrer et bien
tous les messages négatifs arrive arrive
en série je ne suis pas capable il faut
que je m'arrête je suis fatigué tout
tout ce qui fait que ben vous avez envie
de vous arrêter pour ça j'avais trouvé
une parade très très simple je me dis
équipé d'une petite sonnette cette
petite sonnette qui est là et à chaque
fois que j'avais un moment de doute de
peur de crainte
j'active est cette petite sonnette
voilà sur mon vélo est automatiquement
ça me permettait en quelques secondes
quelques minutes de retrouver ma
concentration
alors pour d'autres ça peut être un
bracelet une bague un maillot voilà pour
moi c'était cette petite sonnette et à
chaque fois qu'elle aurait menti c'est
et l art contient de nombreuses fois
tout au long de la traversée
je retrouvais ma concentration et je
savais pourquoi j'étais là et ce que je
devais faire
l'équipe très très important je m'étais
convaincu avant le départ que je devais
entièrement faire confiance à mon équipe
et à aucun moment ne remette les
conseils en doute ce que j'ai fait en
retour en retour alors que j'avais roulé
20h et que j'avais juste envie de dormir
deux heures voire trois un de mes
assistants me dit arnaud il n'y a pas de
souci va dormir trois heures on te
réveilles sont venus me réveiller je me
suis rhabillé en dix minutes je suis
reparti mais il se trouve qu'en fait
j'avais pas dormi trois heures j'avais
dormi 25 minutes 25 minutes donc mais
c'est grâce à des gens comme ça que j'ai
pu réaliser cet exploit et que je peux
aujourd'hui m'exprimer devant vous et je
les remercie systématiquement et puis la
préparation mentale cet engagement c'est
également par dont l'engagement moral
que vous avez j'étais partenaires de
cette association qu'est l'association
rêves qui réalise le rêve dont le rêve
d'enfant pardon dont le pronostic vital
est engagé
et donc je m'étais engagé à reverser une
partie de mes partenaires pour justement
des enfants puissent réaliser leur rêve
et il se trouve que à la fin de notre
parcours on a on a su que trois enfants
avaient pu partir réalisait le rêve dont
un est parti cinq jours l'inversé
l'ouest américain et dans les moments
difficiles au niveau de cette traversée
c'est des choses qui sait des choses qui
vous permettent de remettre les choses
en perspective
et d'avancer en tout cas c'était très
très important et on a été très fier de
pouvoir le faire et je suis revenu vous
l'imaginez je suis revenu de de cette
aventure avec une banque d'image juste
incroyable et je vais vous en partager
quelques unes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
glv tirs sont vraiment trop qu'ils sont
il faut pas pourquoi pour faire monter
en température
incroyable
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
suite à cette aventure ce que j'ai ce
que j'ai retenu c'est surtout deux
choses c'est que la première c'est que
vous seul pouvez décider de votre
potentiel
seul vous pouvez décider de ce que vous
êtes capable de faire ou non
la deuxième chose c'est les limites
quand on est confronté une limite on a
deux choix soit on abandonne soit
justement fait ce fameux pas de côté
pour mettre votre objectif en
perspective et là bas il faut faire un
faux faire appel à votre créativité en
tout cas moi je vous invite à 7 à cette
deuxième option
et puis suite à cette aventure beaucoup
m'ont posé la question alors c'est quoi
le prochain défi c'est quoi la prochaine
aventure
donc je me suis je me suis de nombreux
soit poser la question puisque
j'interviens en entreprise
un documentaire a été réalisé sur sur
notre aventure un livre va sortir dans
quelques mois et je me suis dit mais
qu'est ce que je pouvais faire encore de
plus pour que je puisse partager ce que
j'ai vécu que les gens puissent
ressentir vraiment les émotions
eh bien on a tout simplement décidé en
fait d'importer le concept en france et
donc dans quelques mois
l'arrêt ce cross france va avoir lieu
avec un départ de mandelieu la napoule
et une arrivée à le touquet on devrait
passer d'ailleurs pas très très loin de
roanne
une épreuve qui fait 2600 km que vous
pouvez faire seul en équipe avec ou sans
assistance
en tout cas cette aventure américaine
permis de vivre un moment incroyable
devant vous aujourd'hui et je tenais à
vous remercier beaucoup en tout cas
bonne journée à vous merci
[Musique]
e